pour faire le tour michel bonsoir
bonsoir pas le tour complet mais en tout
cas j'ai choisi trois extraits de trois
films parce que je veux vous m'en
parliez de l'importance qu'il a eue de
ski on viens de l'entendre dire avec mon
petit grain de sel j'ai essayé aussi de
faire changer les choses on commence on
est en 1974 bengo un film qui a marqué
en tout cas les gens qui l'ont vu à
l'époque et après sûr inspiré des
troupes d'octobre
sur aussi la police corrompue sur les
politiciens qui
manipule un ici et là certains
événements ou regarder un extrait et les
gens vont reconnaître willie lamothe et
claude michaux et réjean guénette comme
comédie en écoute
toi tu y es tu repères il ya d'autres
c'est le discret par l'acca voyait
l'acteur savoie ce we need à leur trio
[Musique]
est ce que c'est un bon exemple michel
bégon que ce qu'a voulu faire par une
partie de sa vie jean claude là où il
notamment dans les années 70 puisqu'il a
fait cinq films au cours de ces
décennies il était vraiment cinéaste
justicier un cinéaste citoyens un peu du
poil à gratter là il faut le dire aussi
parce que oui parler de la crise
d'octobre mais montrait la collusion ce
qui se passait derrière comment tirer
les ficelles il y avait une des bavures
policières
puisqu'elle est à la toute fin les
personnages principaux seront les
victimes de la police il montrer tout ce
qui se passait et qui l'agaçait et ça ce
sera là tout au long de sa carrière ça
va revenir les zélés le pouvoir les
coulisses sont des choses des sujets
qu'ils vont fouiller à l'infini je me
suis encore de la faim de bengo quand on
voit ce film on s'en souvient toute
notre ville à la fin dans les rues des
semences on s'aperçoit que maman les
bons sont possibles bon bref ça fait mal
la wii parlez-nous d'amour je vous
demande pas ça à vous est le titre du
prochain film
parlez-nous d'amour une critiques
vitrioliques du milieu de la télévision
de ces tags chaud et c'est michel
tremblay qui signe le scénario jacques
boulanger qui joue dedans donc
l'autodérision on écoute un extrait
vous avez promis une grosse opération
pour est grosse et grosses vous allez
voir voici hunter favoris qui est mon
ami depuis des années
pierre vignaud temps bonjour milliards
da domaine
pour tous et j'espère qu'elle ne va pas
s'ils finissent cédant devant tant
publié qu'à cela
michel tu es est-ce que ce qu'on va leur
diffuser ce qu'on pourrait leur diffusé
aujourd'hui on le re diffusent
régulièrement et c'est une véritable
bombe faut dire que déjà dans les
colombes le film précédent il avait
égratigné la télévision un concours de
chanteurs qui tu es tout à fait
malhonnête à organiser je veux vous
arranger ça avec les politiciens qui
tire les ficelles aussi dense que la
love vraiment c'est une bombe
parlez-nous d'amour et pour jacques
boulanger presqu'une fait quelque chose
parce que dans son propre rôle il
animait une émission de télévision il
était très populaire et ce moment
l'homme est il animait dans le film une
émission de télévision où on voyait que
les producteurs derrière de penser qu'au
profit traiter les femmes mais avec un
mépris infinie les jeunes chanteuses
étaient au bord du suicide les gens des
médias les patineurs faisait du chantage
auprès des gens le public était traité
mesvrin comme les derniers les derniers
et surya des scènes inoubliables par
exemple cette image du public alors des
femmes d'un certain âge et puis d'un
certain poids qu'on voit nue et qui sont
là devant leur janot qu'elle adore tant
sa frappe et puis toutes ces méchancetés
qu'on disait sur aussi bien les artistes
que les gens du public qu'avec cette
préface préoccupations qu'il a eu tout
au long de sa vie de d'accorder une
place égale aux femmes de traiter
correctement les femmes c'était lot dès
son premier scénario trouble-fête dans
les années 60 parce qu'il y avait un
ciné club et puis avait pas de femmes
alors les gods on en veut susciter la
révolution tranquille mais ce soit
beaucoup plus tard bien sûr qu'on va le
voir dans lance et quand dans d'autres
romans changer ou galice associés la
séquence parce qu'elle est une femme
après
des schémas commande d'aller ensuite est
venu ceux ci
ghoga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors michel bon d'abord ceux qui sont
assez vieux se souviennent comment
oublier on entend la musique et envoie
les singles ça a été un coup de circuit
là oui parce que grand succès public
autour de deux millions de spectateurs
le tandem réjean tremblay jean claude
laur a révolutionné la télévision
québécoise d'une part parce qu'on a
amené le hockey à la télévision puis
avait le rip une façon de faire tout
était différent tout était nouveau ont
secoué les habitudes on faisait autre
chose que les feuilletons qui jusque là
était la recette gagnante
et ce sera ça toute sa carrière
télévisuelle parce que la suite c'est
jasmin et là on est dans la diversité
culturelle c'est tout à fait novateur il
ya 10 20 jan o b et jusqu'à district 31
c'est vous dire à quel point cet homme
là a été marquant il était présent au
début des années 60 il le sera jusqu'à
la fin de la décennie qui vient de se
terminer c'est vous dire presque 60 ans
de présence de visuels et puis même un
travail qui peut ressembler au mien cela
voir une coeur cinéma la fin des années
60 a bondi manche où il avait ce
franc-parler qui va caractériser mais
vraiment la personne jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie il y avait quelque chose à dire
c'est un citoyen et il ne s'en cache pas
il ya été critique de cinéma bon
dimanche la fin des années 60 sans doute
effectivement ils disent qu'ils
passaient comme vous ou michele merci
merci m utiles parfois on venait on
voulait quand même
souligner le départ de ceux de ce
réalisateur important chez nous merci
beaucoup au revoir au revoir